tous négatifs ces mots ont fait réagir
depuis quelques semaines les banques
européennes offrent désormais des prêts
hypothécaires à taux négatifs ce qui
revient à payer finalement les clients
pour emprunter le taux d'intérêt imposés
aux banques sur leurs dépôts en europe a
été abaissée à -0 25% ce qui veut dire
que les banques doivent payer pour
laisser dormir leurs liquidités à la
banque centrale européenne
cela a pour but dans le fond d inciter à
prêter davantage aux consommateurs et
aux entreprises en france en allemagne
en finlande litho sur une majorité
d'obligations sont négatifs on va
comprendre quelque chose j'espère avec
hendrix vachon économiste chez
desjardins bros soir pour soi qu'est ce
qui se passe exactement pour qu'on parle
maintenant de tours négatif généralement
une banque centrale lorsqu'elle veut
stimuler l'économie a relevé un peu
l'inflation qu'elle juge qu'il n'est pas
assez élevé elle va baisser ses taux
d'intérêt donc sa maman ça va stimuler
l'économie
par contre en europe on a tellement
baissé les taux long terme on and on
atteint 11 00 pour ça donc la pression
c'est comme si l'économie avait encore
besoin d'être stimulé donc falloir faire
plus nous ayons essayé des achats
d'actifs dont qui achètent beaucoup de
titres gouvernementaux essentiellement
pour essayer maintenant de baisser des
taux à plus long terme et ensuite même
quand ça ça semble non suffisant ils ont
opté pour une autre stratégie c'est de
baisser même les taux directeur en
dessous la barre du zéro donc c'est
quand même moins chercher de la marge de
manoeuvre est tous les machins neufs
disponibles
oui exactement donc on se fait payer
pour emprunter en quelque sorte c'est
pas transmis totalement la aux clients
de quelques coqs ont pesé mentionné
d'entrée de jeu mais l'idée c'est so
sick
quant au gaz ou le marché obligataire
les gouvernements les taux obligataires
en europe beaucoup taux obligataires
sont descendues en dessous de zéro on
notera suivi la tendance des taux
directeurs
donc oui les gouvernements présentement
d'europe l'aca plusieurs gouvernements
se font payer pour emprunter et donc ça
devient pour l'investisseur qui
achèteraient une obligation ou pour la
banque ou les humbles et la firme
d'investissement qui achète des
obligations
c'est plus intéressant dans les pertes
deux là
argent avec un taux négatif ça peut
aller risquer dans le marché s'annonce
sans oublier contre intuitif mais
souvent que les grands investisseurs eux
ils regardent pas décemment juste le
taux obligataires en garde le prix de
l'obligation bien sûr esprit-là lui
continuent d'augmenter plus que le taux
diminue le taux d'intérêt la puce
l'obligation mais le laval à l'aviation
et elle continue à augmenter
y en a encore qui me disent que ça va
continuer d'augmenter donc pour avoir un
potentiel de gains encore qui voile
par contre le commun des mortels acheter
une obligation qu'il faut payer à chaque
année un coupon c'est bien ça vient
d'ici là qu'on comprend oui exactement
c'est un peu on va regarder justement un
graphique que vous avez préparé sur les
obligations en europe dans les pays
européens allemagne france suisse suède
et danemark
on parle de 2013 et on voit clairement
que l'obligation 10 ans est rendu
clairement vous présente qu'un autre
aspect aussi mentionné c'est quelqu'un
que beaucoup d'argent à placer on peut
c'est pas facile de médecins en argent
comptant dont 15 enfants devraient
construire un coffre-fort puisse assurer
la sécurité assurée ça donc
l'alternative de payer nos obligations
qu'un léger taux négatif est encore
acceptable
donc c'est une autre raison d'appeler
les grands investisseurs ont le choix
soit en argent comptant ou cesser ces
produits là d'un taux négatif donc c'est
encore un autre comme c'est le cas des
décisions parce que ce que vous me dites
dans le fond c'est qu'on pourrait songer
à vouloir de l'argent comptant plutôt
que laisser son argent sur les marchés
voyage il ya toujours de l'option de
d'avoir l'argent liquide la possession
oui mais pour des grands des grands
déposants dont plusieurs milliards à
déposer à la banque qu'elle va tirer une
somme d'un million ça serait assez
compliqué prenant retiré par le
transporter et à placer sécurisé donc
nous pour se placer à une obligation
taux négatif c'est ça peut être plus
avantageux encore alors ça c'est ce site
obligataires souverains de 10 ans
l'autre à fixer le taux sur les dépôts
sur les dépôts de clients encore une
fois allemagne pays-bas lettonie suisse
danemark luxe en vo et pas partout en
europe puisque
venant les données officielles ça c'est
des moyennes mais qui sont
comptabilisées par pays mais se dit pays
qui sont assistées pays où on voit que
dans les données officielles
on est allé en territoire négatif sur
les dépôts des clients depuis 2015
d'ailleurs oui alex est allé si vite en
suisse là c'est allé assez vite c'est
pour les dépôts en suisse le cette série
là pour les dépôts de cent mille francs
et plus donc c'est les gros déposants ce
que les petits déposants eux sont charge
d'intérêt négatifs parce qu il resterait
assez vite tenté de retirer leurs dépôts
s'est passé non plus qu'on veut imaginer
tout le monde sortait leur argent du
système bancaire
bayard et plus d'argent à prêter pour
les hypothèques pour l'investissement
donc la peau de ce moteur est totalement
inefficace
donc on n'est pas la limite du tolérable
on s'en approche plus on le voit qu'on
affronte en train de le tester mais
aussi pour les pour les déposants les
entreprises les ménages et ckoi
l'efficacité d'avoir des politiques de
taux négatifs
le problème s'il y en a qui disent de
plus en plus que l'efficacité des petit
matin est en train de diminuer
vraiment c'est d'entrée de jeu ils font
ça pour stimuler le crédit mais ce qu'on
voit l'europe c'est que les crédits
augmentent c'est pas beaucoup accéléré
dans les dernières années donc des
doutes à l'effet que les les taux
négatifs vont davantage créer de donner
de crédit mais d'autres canal de
transport d'autres canaux de
transmission de la politique monétaire
outre l'effet de richesse donc à les
prix des maisons des bourses augmente
avec les politiques monétaires
accommodantes
mais les gens peuvent se sentir plus
riches et à terme dépenser plus encore
là il ya une limite on peut pas
continuellement surévalué les prix des
maisons parce que je vais lui de la
valeur des bourses maintenant c'est bien
pour grey avoir des corrections donc
peut pas utiliser cependant d antan non
plus et l'autre canal c'est le taux de
change mais encore là si toutes les
banques centrales des prix si leur
monnaie en même temps avec des potes
pointer accommodante
ben y'a plus de gains non les comparant
vis-à-vis de la personne qui me revois
ces exportations augmenter est ce que ça
pourrait arriver au canada des taux
négatifs imposer mon auto son directeur
sont bien installés en territoire
positif faudrait d'abord qu'il ya des
signes que l'économie au canada voire
ralenti on abaisserait les taux près de
zéro ensuite on peut utiliser d'autres
outils comme des achats d'actifs
puis ultima si ça ça ne suffirait pas
l'on pourrait aller avec des détours
négatif on est encore loin
loin n'est pas spanos pas demain matin
hendrix vachon merci beaucoup
le plaisir si